- Four hundred trillion to one,
the odds of becoming a human being.
(dramatic music)
You choose where you're looking for
because what you look for, you find.
That's how fucking life works.
You know, being successful takes
several different variables
I think self awareness is number one.
If you don't know yourself
and you don't know what you're good at,
you've got no shot because you're gonna be
spinning your wheels.
I think work ethic is at the top.
Nobody, nobody watching this right now
knows anybody that's successful at all
that hasn't put in
serious amounts of work.
Very quickly, I can tell
you, you need to get
every voice out of your
head besides yourself
and you need to love yourself.
You will win.
Can't live your life based on
other people's point of view.
I am tired of people not
starting and living their life
on one very simple thing
which is they're worried
about what other people think.
Learn the work ethic and the skills
that match your ambition.
You get to live life one time.
And this is the time right now
to understand what's actually happening
and to actually map your
behavior to something
that will impact you
for the next 80 years.
Pay the fuck attention to
who's giving you the advice.
Who's giving the advice?
And more importantly,
if you live your life
where you're comfortable
taking somebody else's
point of view on how you
should fucking live your life,
you deserve to live.
Figure out what you
fucking puts you on fire
and you're half way decent at
and become tunnel fucking visioned.
I only want one thing
for people that I have.
Really, outside of health, the
only thing I wish for people
is them to love what
they do as much as I do.
(music builds)
It's not that you can't,
it's that you're not willing
to give up dumb shit for a better life.
It's very very simple.
Put yourself in a position to succeed.
Figure out who you
really are and figure out
if what you're talking is being mapped
by what you're doing
because the second you put
those things together,
shit fucking unlocks.
Who's fucking permission
are you looking for?
Go do your thing.
You're gonna die.
'Cause nobody's gonna
give a fuck when you die.
Why the fuck do you worry
about their opinions
while you're alive?
(dramatic music)
I just can't explain to
everybody like clearer,
when you figure out who
you are and do all that,
you win.
Regardless of what you're
trying to accomplish,
you've gotta tell the world about it.
This is now the world.
If you're not betting on
this, you're finished.